tessa tell me this what is the thing
between about you and goats
oh um well i oh so i think i kind of
look like one in the sense because my
my eyes are sort of far they're spaced
far apart
and so there was this photograph that
was taken of me um
and i found a photograph that i looked
that i looked similar to that goat and
so in a haired makeup trailer i was
making in london this film annihilation
and we had it in the hair and makeup
trailer and i think at some point i
said something about it in an interview
and someone started this
this um this twitter account called
tessa as goats so they
every day they post a photograph of me
and a photograph of a goat that looks
like me
this is not making this up you'll like
this claudia so
some of them some of them are very
simple this is you in a stripy dress
and all they have to do is find a stripy
goat not hard to do
there you go now the next one
this is uh you in a straw hat surely
we'll find a gold and a straw hat
yes they did there you go beautiful
now this is harder this is you with
firemen
now that you know you don't immediately
think well there's bound to be a picture
of a goat with firemen
but there is
those firemen look happier than the
other fighters
i mean i don't blame them now this is
very difficult
this is you as valkyrie on a horse
will there be a picture of a goat on a
horse
yes there is i feel like that goat was
on that horse for
a nanosecond they just got it in time
yeah mid-hop and and finally
this is tessa on a motorbike in men in
black international
will there be a picture of a goat as a
pillion passenger
on a motorbike why yes they're real
how comfortable does that go very good
you